let's talk about net neutrality would do
in a bunch about it I really beyond the
money in politics thing I think this is
the most important thing going on right
now
to the FCC struck down net neutrality
didn't look like they were gonna do but
they did
net neutrality the basic principle that
everyone deserves
mobile Internet access and that the
Internet Service Providers
have to provide the highway should be
equal for everybody
now they've flip that so that the
companies can probably internet
so if you don't think that's important
to you let's say you're someone who
watches the Young Turks there's a chance
right there watching this
and you believe in alternate media well
with Time Warner which owns CNN says
when we don't like the Young Turks their
not given appropriate message well then
they can actually start Prada Ling
the speed with which you get the Young
Turks videos get these businesses
hugely important and especially now
anytime when
the mainstream media has failed us
miserably in cable news is a disaster
and all that so again we'll start with
the broadening
was the internet broken I didn't know it
you know any was there was there really
a problem here that the FCC had to jump
in
and get involved it wasn't are you
finding that the Internet was pretty was
only broke into the people who were
suddenly losing their power and money
picnic that's who was broken the rest of
us were like a walk
we have more power and access to our
consumers and to our audience directly
now
this is amazing this is like you know
the sixties all over again but farrow's
right but it's okay
free let anybody
is that a free love with other people a
lot of porn up way
right always you know that the
front-runner but yeah it was not broken
I just love the way they're catching is
the FCC to their like trying to say
but its consumer if your gonna be happy
because when you're streaming your
Netflix video
there'll be no glitches because will
give Netflix and people like that
priority
which you know I get it at 2 a.m. when
I'm watching the bridge I wanna you know
avid
flowing correctly but a yab
this is all based on the fact that and
everyone to play
the fair don't worry everyone going to
be there about their
so you give me the perfect segue so
we've got a quote from the FCC Chairman
he said very direct the proposal would
establish that behavior
harmful to consumers are competition by
limiting the openness
at the internet will not be permitted
now that sounds nice and that sort of
sounds like what you're saying but it
doesn't there's no
nothing there's no teeth in that they're
they're gonna they just decided to
change
what was working and then say well we
promise tonight screw it up
any for yeah but they're up for bid you
say fuck you know
here alright woefully of auto show is
about oxygen
is there anything we can do about well
first we gotta get through though
our voter fraud because there are four
Obama
through fuckin history and so make sure
you don't have to have an idea to get
both and I'm the same guy that thinks
this is another important lot apart at
the same exact mindset is that is said
artificial problem to take command back
from people who were
getting power from those other stories
we were talking about earlier that
you're changing the way we make money
you came here for two hours now we gotta
workable the law yet talk with you going
with the little bit of a conspiracy
theory here could this possibly be why
CNN
gave us three months or whatever it is a
24-hour plane coverage
because they want to keep our eyes of
the real problems
because they are owned by Johnny
corporate conglomerates that
gain access and gain the money that
you're talking about and when we're the
ones threatening them
up course you could see it that way but
really CNN once your eyes just to be on
them they don't care what you're
ignoring
they just want their I mean they have
the best ratings in 15 years or
something like that to reset
it yeah so I i'm not a I'm not want the
people sitting in a room and you know
making up decisions about this you don't
need a conspiracy theory into the system
is already
you know against us cell yep that's my
personal view
do we need what you've been talking
about a couple times so far do we need
this
groundswell support starting at the
bottom
people taking to Twitter Facebook you
know the 99 percent all that
thing is that the only way we have a
chance to get this thing fixed when have
we not
mean when is that not been the case when
is that not work
yeah and always works same key
seem like everytime like works every
time to put an end to it
just gonna look for the key i'm too busy
and other stuff I gotta do
something to do with some it'll help a
lock for me where's everyone at once
it's like one of those nuclear missile
things are two people that put the key
in birds and
everyone key turn our house and I do
believe that
innovation I mean you know the Internet
and
and everything around it you know is is
all about young minds innovating
E with things that we can even
begin to ponder and I I think there's
going to be some young
Turk somewhere in the back cover room in
hell be like
I figure out a way to open up me a
billion times this over here this space
and will all jump in there and the
corporation's ability
what there wasn't any water or stop by
any more
were all over there are you know knows I
the job in control that mean someone to
do it again
yeah that's the way it is that's the way
innovation works that's the way it
that's the way our democracy works that
way
evolution works at box rapid-fire yeah
yeah know Kelly Carlin you gave me a
little hope at the end of the second I
did not know
that there was hope when you when it
comes to the FCC but apparently there
up